to my right is bounty law series lead  and jake cahill himself rick dalton and  to my left is rick stunt double cliff  booth  so Rick explain to the audience exactly  what it is a stunt double does actors  are required to do a lot of dangerous  stuff cliff here is meant to help carry  the load is that how you describe your  job cliff what carrying his load adds  about right  [Music]  my hands are registered as lethal  weapons we get into a fight I  accidentally kill you I go to jail  anybody accidentally kills anybody in  fight they go to jail it's called  manslaughter  [Music]  [Music]  that was the best acting I've ever seen  in my whole life thank you  [Music]